hello everyone welcome to another game
from round seven of the 2019 us
championship like we mentioned I
released the first video a bit earlier
today so I as I was planning to do
another one a lot of you have suggested
this game and for good reason
I once I've seen at once I saw it it was
just you know a wonderful game but we'll
get back to that and now for those of
you who might be interested before we
check out the game a subscriber sent me
a short chest animation it's somewhat 1
minute long it's well it's it's a chest
animation with some soothing music about
a certain game played by Magnus Carlsen
so if you would enjoy checking it out
it's like I said less than a minute
don't think - it will be in the
description below first thing you'll see
so you know if that's something you
might enjoy to check it out if not
returning to the game we have a
wonderful game between ray Robson and
Samuel 7 and without further ado let's
let's just dive straight into it
Robson has the white pieces and he opens
with E 4 we have E 5 Knight to f3 Knight
to c6 and Bishop to b5 the real opus is
on the board Knight to f6 the Berlin
defense and d3 now now we will have the
same line but of the c5 that was played
a few rounds ago in the same
championship between Fabiana Khurana and
Jeffrey's young Bishop captures D
captures and now castles and here in
this position she went Queen to e7 but
here 7 goes for a different line he
defends the e5 pawn with Knight to d7
and ok so it's a well known line we have
c3 by white repairs before in some not
so distant future we have castles by 7
and d4 now challenging the Bishop on c5
push her back to d6 and here Bishop to
g5 now attacking the Queen and here we
have a very interesting position because
this was the position on the board in
2017 in the first match between
stockfish and alpha 0 and alpha 0 in
this position after stalkerish played
the Bishop to g5 alpha went Queen to d8
but in this game 7 deviates from this
line he went he was 4 f6 and this is you
know this is a bold maneuver if you were
in sevens who's here if he knew that
alpha 0
t8 here will you play the move alpha
zero plate or would you just say now
I'll just play something different so
you know definitely a courageous
maneuver but okay Bishop is challenging
out Bishop to h4 and only now Queen goes
to e8 we have Knight B to d2 and Knight
the b6 buy black frame the light square
bishop and the knight can now be
developed on the Queen side and here
there is a one-game known where bishop
to g3 was played the nidus versus that
has nickel were Rose Nico won the game
in 2019 but here we have h3 and it is as
of this moment unmoved well that we have
a completely new game
Robson goes for this h3 idea but here 7
well takes advantage of this h3 move
instead of rush up to g3 and in a very
nice way he goes he captures on d4 now
just opening up an attack towards this
diagonal so now you will not be able to
play Bishop to g3 anymore we have seek
after Sun before and now Queen to g6
just with further pressure towards the
the g6 pawn and also pressuring the e4
pawn we have kinked the h1 not wanting
to stay on the G file and here Bishop to
e6 just developing we have a three by
white and Bishop Bishop f4 now and also
I forgot to mention if you're interested
in that game between stokesian alpha
zero I will also put a link to that in
the description below so feel free to
check it out and also I'll put the game
of Fabiano versus Jeffries young also in
the description below you know I'll just
put a lot of things in the description
below if you want to check it out okay
rook to e1 would further defense of the
e4 pawn here black goes
f5 challenging White's very strong
center here he captures on f5 Bishop
captures on f5 and now Queen to b3 check
first we have Knight to d5 blocking and
here it's a very delicate position and
well it's hard to decide for white what
to do you know danger lurks everywhere
the best thing for white is to prepare
Knight e5 to go Knight to c4
if bishop to afford to even give up the
exchange with rook captures after Queen
captures rook to e1 develop the rook
forces the Queen back Queen g6 and 995
and here you would have a very strong
night I mean five perhaps the black will
not be able to challenge it at least
some conversation for the rook maybe
and also if black captures then you get
a very strong past bond which now
definitely is compensation for some
compensation for the exchange but after
this Knight to d5 move Robson decides to
go for Queen captures on b7 and Queen
captures on b7 simply doesn't work why
it doesn't work well for a specific
reason first rook a to b8 attacks the
Queen Queen has to move Queen captures
on a7 is played and now we have rook
captures and v2 with a double attack on
the knight the bishop is now attacking
the knight and also the rook so what do
you do here here Robson went Knight to
c4 now preparing to go and hoping to go
to e5 as the rook is now under attack on
b2 so you should move the rook but you
know feel free to pause the video here
and try to find well find the winning
line for white as Knight the c-4 simply
is too slow I'll give you a couple of
seconds as usual if you're you know able
to do it congratulations you know you
are an excellent player and for those
who just want to enjoy the show if you
found moving the rook anywhere I did not
ask you to pause the video to move the
rook I asked you to post video to find
Bishop captures on h3 and I'll pretty
much anything black does well anything
white does will win you the game for
example if you have to capture it if you
try something like g3 then you get rook
captures not have to again you can't
capture anything the you know mate is
still to follow and if rook to g1 then
just Queen to e4 pressuring the knight
here also now checkmate will follow you
cannot block with 92 or 95 as the bishop
covers both of those squares so this
would be out quickly quickly over after
this Bishop captures on h3 Robson went G
captures on h3 and here we have Queen to
d3
Queen to h5 was also possible with the
same idea that the knight on f3 is under
attack a brocade Queen to d3 attacking
the knight and now kink the g2 defending
and here seven decides to attack the
knight twice now so he just moves the
Bishop Bishop d6 freeing up the attack
from the rook towards the knight on f3
and Knight the g1 getting the night owl
the way also keeping an eye on the f3
square but well it doesn't work so once
again feel free to pause the video here
and try to find the win it's a forced
checkmate in three so not not too
difficult you know for for for a weekday
I'll give you a couple of seconds as
usual so for those who were able to do
it congratulations you are an excellent
Mader in three and for those who just
wanna enjoy show it's just rook captures
an f2 and now if you go back let's say
working each one then rook to H 2 will
be checkmate and if not the move you had
to find after Bishop captures an f2 now
the move of course is and I'm sure you
all see it Queen - not there but the g3
check as the bishop is pinned from the
rook and now there's nothing to do
anymore wherever the king goes it's a
rockin to F 1 followed by Queen captures
or row captures an F - checkmate
or if King to h1 then Quinta H 1 will be
checkmate as the bishop also controls
the h2 square now so quite a lovely game
from from Samuel 7 in this well
wonderful line of the Berlin seems like
there are a lot more decisive games in
the Brillion defense then there were
let's say some 15 or 20 years ago it's
you know it became like maybe it became
a very dynamic opening who knows as a
lot of a lot of other ideas are
happening you know remember kramnik
versus RN and in the candidates or
something like that but yeah a very
exciting moment where were seven
deviated from the alpha zero line I
don't know well I always when I first
started playing chess and I I often used
to memorize shorter games by hearts
especially morphus games Anderson's game
starts to sound like that and then when
I had like a position
I knew how Morphy played something here
and then I will always play it because
if more if he played it then I I'm you
know I know I know
I mean I'm in good position yeah that's
what I mean so when alpha zero plays a
move and you deviate from it it's a well
either good preparation or or or who
knows what it is but they're definitely
exciting move but yeah after this Queen
nice wing to g3 check rail Robson
resigned the game and a very nice
victory for Samuel Simeon for those of
you who have seen my previous video you
have also seen the standings but in case
you haven't after seven rounds it's
Hikaru Nakamura in first place with five
points then three people four and half a
Caruana Domingues Paris in Savannah with
this great victory of Robson and then as
they follow was the soldierfish young
Alexander Linderman Samuel Shanklin Rae
Robson after this loss of Underland what
was an aqua bein after that loss to to
Nakamura if you haven't seen it I will
also put a link to that game in the
description below so that's like the
fifth link but you know and the timur
grave sadly in last place after seven
rounds yeah a lot of action going on in
the description below so do check it out
definitely check out the animation the
alpha zero game you know all the games
if you haven't and you know just enjoy
and i would like to thank Dennis
flatland and Dennis a time the hoodie
guy who more than welcome to challenge
humanly chess rohan Padano doober of
Cuyahoga Nikolas Richmond and Curtis
Bellamy for a condition to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you could check to on my
previous video Sarah thank you for
watching and I will see you soon with
some more interesting content hopefully
you know just checking up what's what
checking up on your suggestions and we
will be continuing the cup of lanka saga
of course but I always have to stress
this out we do have to cover the current
events as well yeah I think oh and I
will see you soon